[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the harry potter books
the harry potter films and none other
than severus snape
more specifically we're going to be
taking a look at snape's character
and uncovering a few little-known facts
about snape
that only book readers will know that's
right
the films left things out if you haven't
read the books then your next move
should be a continue watching this video
then
b by the complete harry potter book set
and get to reading
now the first thing worth mentioning is
that snape is quite different from book
to film
not just in his actions but in his
demeanor his character while very
similar in some ways
has a bit of a different undertone alan
rickman's portrayal was
excellent in fact to me it was one of
the best acting performances
in any role ever but that certainly
doesn't mean that the films
didn't take certain liberties where they
could book snape was arrogant
apathetic and seemingly without any kind
of moral compass
he showed blatant favoritism towards
students of his house southern bullied
students until they couldn't cope
anymore
and showed very little indication of
valuing other human lives
he was a vindictive and cruel man that
would often let his emotions get the
better of him
in the form of anger-fueled outbursts
movie snape was a little frightening at
times
and quite strict feared but overall was
not nearly as bad as the snape
from the books movie snape also bullied
students
a little but it was all just toned down
to a much more reasonable level
furthermore he was much more in control
of his emotions he was controlled
brooding and calculating rather than
outwardly emotional and
vengeful with all of this said there are
a few things that we need to bear in
mind
first of all snape is in the films far
less than he is in the books
the films are much more condensed and
for this reason the
highlight reel of snape that we get may
not be indicative of his true nature
furthermore the books are written much
more from the perspective of harry
who is naturally heavily biased towards
snape for this reason
looking at snape through the lens of
harry may have inflated how bad
he actually was perhaps the film snape
actually gave a better
unbiased impression of what snape was
really like
one thing is for certain however
moviegoers are certainly more forgiving
of snape
than book readers and that's because
they weren't exposed to the
darker snape that others had become
accustomed to when snape's true
motivations were revealed in the last
book
film the film version had somehow
vindicated himself
whereas book snape was possibly not
worthy of this same
vindication with all of this in mind i
want to look at five things that
moviegoers want to know about the snape
from the books vive actions that he took
or things that he was a part of
that were entirely left out of the films
let's dive into it
number one james potter saved his life
now it shouldn't come as a surprise to
anyone
snape and harry's father james didn't
get along
in fact they were the biggest of enemies
rivals who were both in pursuit of lily
evans heart
in school james was awful to snape as
were the other marauders
snape was bullied for being different
and being so different
meant that he was a constant target for
the marauders antics
the movies touch on snape's relationship
with james but one thing they neglected
to include
was the fact that james once saved
snape's life one day while bullying
snape
the antics of the marauders got out of
hand putting snape's life
in danger when james recognized that the
prank had gotten outrageously out of
hand
he ended up saving snape's life however
it's also worth noting that snape didn't
see james's actions as
heroism he saw it as james simply
looking out for himself
so that he wouldn't be punished which is
probably the case
number two snape told voldemort about
the prophecy
the prophecy in question is of course
the one foretold by sybil trelawny in
hogsmeade pub in the year 1980
we know sybil as the professor of
divination at hogwarts
and we know that she has a track record
of successful predictions
predicting at the end of the 93-94
school year
that pettigrew would escape and that
voldemort would return
however she was not always so successful
and in 1980
found herself in the hogsmeade pub with
dumbledore interviewing for her post as
professor
while her track record was not good at
this time dumbledore gave her a chance
because she was the great granddaughter
of famous seer
cassandra trolloni during her interview
a disappointed and
unimpressed dumbledore began to lose
interest when suddenly
sybil entered a trance in her trance
civil spoke of the famous prophecy
that we all know explaining that
voldemort would be defeated
it spoke of a boy that would be born at
the end of july
that possessed the power to defeat the
dark lord himself
in harry potter and the order of the
phoenix dumbledore mentions to
that a spy overheard simple trolone's
prediction and relayed all of the
information to voldemort
what we later learn is that this spy was
in fact
severus snape a loyal death eater at the
time
snape was hoping to build brownie points
with voldemort but his biggest error
here was that he failed to make the
connection between the prophecy
and lily evans life number three snape
is responsible for lupin
losing his job in the prison of azkaban
hogwarts is once again graced with a new
defense against the dark arts professor
but this time it's someone with quite a
few close personal connections to harry
remus lupin remus was born a wizard but
later in life became a werewolf
after being attacked by notorious
werewolf fenrir greyback
given that there was a considerable
amount of stigma towards werewolves in
the wizarding world
remus and his friends always tried their
best to keep his werewolf status a
secret
at the end of the school year in the
prisoner of azkaban film remus is seen
packing up his desk
he explains to harry that word had
gotten out regarding his werewolf status
and that hogwarts had become inundated
with angry messages from parents
who are not happy with the situation
this is why remus lost his job
in the book however it's actually snape
who was responsible for remus losing his
position
snape despised remus and wanted him to
leave hogwarts
which prompted him to tell his students
about remus secret
number four snape protected harry from
umbridge
in the order of the phoenix dolores
umbridge had essentially taken over
hogwarts
she started as a new defense against a
dark arts professor and quickly advanced
to become hogwarts high inquisitor
then headmaster while presiding over the
school she abused her power
and put all sorts of rules in place that
oppressed students umbridge very much
aware of harry's antics
would continually challenge and question
him hoping
that he would divulge information about
dumbledore who is now at large
as well as serious in order to extract
this information from harry
umbridge gets a truth potion from snape
in the hopes that harry would divulge
every piece of information he knew
about the order of the phoenix however
what film goers won't know about this
part of the story
is that snape actually gave umbridge a
fake truth potion
this is later reinforced by dumbledore
when addressing harry
it was he too who gave professor
umbridge fake veritas serum
when she was attempting to force you to
tell of sirius's whereabouts
number five snape passed on the message
that sirius black had been captured
in order of the phoenix piggy backing
off this last point when harry is
captured by umbridge
he tries to tell snape that voldemort is
holding serious captive
at the department of mysteries to this
remark snape plays dumb
essentially ignoring what harry has just
told him in the film
we never really get any clarification as
to whether or not snape passed the
message on
but in the book dumbledore later
clarifies that snape did in fact relay
the message
which is why the order of the phoenix
showed up to save harry and his friends
and that's it for this video did you
know all of these little factoids about
snape
which snape did you prefer let me know
in the comment section
below until next time always
[Music]
you